your brand is dying that's not true is
it it's going to continue dying because
of the type of content that you push
it's not really sure can I pull up your
analytics your shit's on the down curve
brother
your career is going down
bro
that's off the flip and I mean at least
mine is like pretty flat but that is
treacherous man you are going down like
the Titanic brother that is rough
I'm taking a a little bit of a break
from YouTube because I've been getting a
lot of heat on the internet so I just
wanted to take a step back tough being
out there as a Creator huh I don't think
you're gonna make it you see if you have
thin skin like that
[Music]